with 314 episodes three movies in a web
exclusive it can be difficult to
determine which order to watch Stargate
in
let's talk about that welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
[Music]
before we get into this video I would
like to announce a new project from
Sidetrack 9 chevrons.com
your dedicated source for Stargate news
which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com
now the order I'm going to tell you
today is going to be the chronological
order of how events played out in the
Stargate Universe there is going to be
one addendum and that's going to be the
first entry on the list which is
Stargate Origins now many fans including
myself don't actually consider Stargate
Origins to be Canon however because it
was set in 1939 it does technically
count as the first instance of Stargate
although if I was to recommend it at all
it would be the very last thing you
watched instead the very first instance
of Target that anyone should be watching
is the Stargate movie which is produced
in 1994 by Roland Emerick and Dean
Devlin it's movie star Kurt Russell is
Jack O'Neill and James Spader with
Daniel Jackson the movie starts with the
Stargate being discovered and Daniel
Jackson is the guy who essentially
figures out how it works they figure out
how to open the gate and they go to
abidos once there they discover that the
population of the planet is enslaved by
a powerful alien posing as the ancient
Egyptian god Ra it's up to the team to
free the people and Destroy ra whilst
also figuring out a way to get home the
movie is what kick-started everything
without the movie we wouldn't have sg1
we wouldn't have Atlantis or universe so
for anyone watching Stargate you should
always start with the movie moving on
directly from the movie we'll start on
Stargate sg1 now this is going to be the
longest run you're going to have on any
of this series we're going to talk about
today because from series one to seven
you're not going to be watching anything
else Stargate sg1 ran from 1997 all the
way up to 2007. and sg1 is a crucial
Foundation to the entire Stargate
franchise it builds a lot of the world
and a lot of the law surrounding what is
going to come up in later seasons and
some of this law even spawns new series
such as Stargate Atlantis and Stargate
Universe Stargate sg1 expands upon the
movie and introduces us to new
characters such as major Samantha Carter
and tilk tilk is an alien a former first
Prime to the enemy which is the Goa
award which we now know is what Ra was
in the movie
the gold are a powerful parasitical
beings who take over human hosts and
then pose as their gods now it's not
just ancient Egyptian gods that they
pose as throughout the many religions
that have been here on Earth the guy
will take inspiration from all of them
and pose as the gods from those specific
religions SG-1 is arguably the most
popular series but that's probably
because there was so much of it from
seasons one to seven so much happens and
it's gonna be such a fun ride
now once you have completed season seven
you can actually start watching season
eight but only watch the first two
episodes which are called New Order part
one and part two new order part one and
two is essentially the battle for Earth
the gold system Lord Anubis is about to
attack Earth and it's up to the team
SG-1 to try and destroy him to try and
stop him from taking over the planet a
lot happens in this two part so I'm not
going to spoil anything for anyone who
hasn't watched Stargate yet but these
two episodes pave the way for the next
series on the list which is Stargate
Atlantis so once you've finished
episodes one and two of season eight of
sg1 you can watch the first two episodes
of Stargate Atlantis season one which is
entitled rising and hide and seek this
is going to establish what Stargate
Atlantis is all about it's an expedition
sent to the lost city of Atlantis which
was created by the Ancients it
establishes where they are it
establishes their place in the galaxy
and it establishes a new threat The
Wraith cut off from home
alone in the new Galaxy they have to
fight to survive and they meet some very
interesting people along the way from
then on you can alternate between
episodes so from Stargate SG-1 Seasons
eight to ten and Stargate Atlantis
seasons one to three for example
Stargate SG-1 season eight episode three
directly following on from that stoggy
Atlantis season one episode three and
then watch episode 4 from sg1 episode 4
from Atlantis episode five from sg1
episode 5 from Atlantis do that up until
you have finished sg1 at season 10. no
spoilers
but once you finish season 10 of sg1
stop watching anything else
instead watch the direct DVD movie
Stargate The Arc of truth because this
neatly ties up and adds a nice little
bookend to the Ori storyline
you should have just finished season
three of Stargate Atlantis so directly
after the Arc of Truth you can watch
season four but only watch the first
episode to begin with which is called
search and rescue after that you want to
move on to the final sg1 Story start it
Continuum Stargate Continuum is the last
directed DVD movie that we ever got from
Stargate sg1 and it brings back a really
old foe in a really good way it's
probably my favorite director DVD movie
it is better than the Arc of Truth and
it does Tire Fest you want in quite a
nice little way once you've finished
Continuum you can then watch the rest of
season four of Stargate Atlantis and
season five now season five was the
final installment for Stargate Atlantis
however there is another series that
spawned at the back end of Stargate
atlantis's final season Stargate
Universe and you can watch both seasons
of that all in one sitting essentially
Stargate Universe follows the crew of
Icarus base who managed to dial the
ninth Chevron and find themselves on an
ancient ship called Destiny trapped and
alone the crew have to fight to survive
that's stock universe is a very
contentious topic some people love it
some people hate it however it is still
stuck now season two does leave you on a
big Cliffhanger and we are yet to see a
resolution for it after you finish
season two of universe this is the last
thing we see from Stargate however going
back to what I said at the beginning of
the video Stargate Origins is an
optional watch I would place it here
after watching Stargate Universe because
Target Universe ended in 2011. Stargate
Origins came out in 2018 so it's the
newest thing we've had although probably
not canon now this isn't the only way
you can watch Stargate of course you can
watch all of sg1 then all of Atlantis
and then all of universe but if you want
to watch it with continuity this is the
best way to do it in the comment section
down below let me know your favorite
episode from either sg1 Atlantis or
universe and whilst you're down there
hit subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker hit the join button
down below thank you so much for
watching
and I'll see you next week
[Music]